KOREAN ARMY.
TONIGHT U.S. OFFICIALS TELL CNN
THEY WON'T COMMENT ON THEIR
ANALYSIS OF THIS STUNNING NORTH
KOREAN PROPAGANDA TAPE.
THE VIDEO FEATURES TWO BROTHERS
OF AMERICAN HERITAGE IN
PYONGYANG, SPEAKING IN WHAT ONE
EXPERT CALLS A NORTH KOREAN
ACCENT AS THEY PLEDGE THEIR
LOYALTY TO KIM JONG-UN AND SLAM
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Translator: THE AMERICAN
IMPERIALISM, THE UNITED STATES
WANTS TO CONQUER THE WORLD,
PURSUING ANTI-NORTH KOREAN
POLICY, TRYING TO TAKE OVER
ASIA.
>> Reporter: U.S. BASED SOURCES
SAY THE STORY OF HOW THE MEN WHO
ARE HALF AMERICAN CAME TO
SUPPORT THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR BEGAN MORE THAN 50
YEARS AGO, BEFORE THEY WERE
BORN.
THEY'RE THE SONS OF JAMES JOSEPH
DRESS KNOCK, FORMER AMERICAN
SOLDIER THAT DEFECTED TO NORTH
KOREA IN 1962.
>> Translator: THE UNITED STATES
MUST ABANDON ITS ANTI-NORTH
KOREAN POLICY.
ITS DONE A LOT OF BAD THINGS.
>> Reporter: THEY WERE BORN IN
NORTH KOREA AND BY ALL ACCOUNTS
NEVER LIVED OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY.
JAMES SAYS HE IS A CAPTAIN IN
THE NORTH KOREAN ARMY.
>> I AM NOT SURE THIS IS
ACTUALLY REAL.
IT MIGHT AS WELL JUST BE A
BROKEN DOWN EMPLOY.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO
REPORTS, HE DESERTED HIS UNIT,
WALKED ACROSS THE DMZ IN 1962
BECAUSE HE FEARED COURT-MARTIAL
OVER A FORGED SIGNATURE.
THEY SAY THE NORTH KOREANS
ARRANGED A MARRIAGE WITH A
ROMANIAN WOMAN.
TED AND JAMES BORN 20 YEARS
LATER.
THEIR MOTHER DIED AND THEIR
FATHER IS BELIEVED TO BE STILL
ALIVE IN NORTH KOREA AND
APPEARED IN THIS 2006
DOCUMENTARY.
A HUMAN RIGHTS ADVOCATE KNOWS
THEIR EXTENDED FAMILY.
>> ALTHOUGH THEY LIVED THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES UNDER STRICT
SURVEILLANCE, THEY HAVE BEEN
PROTECTED TO A CERTAIN EXTENT
BECAUSE THEY'RE SUCH A GREAT
PROPAGANDA ASSET.
>> Reporter: THE BROTHERS AND
THEIR FATHER ACTED IN NORTH
KOREAN PROPAGANDA MOVIES,
PLAYING THE EVIL AMERICAN.
AS FOR THIS INTERVIEW IT IS NOT
CLEAR IF THE BROTHERS WERE
FORCED TO SAY THOSE THINGS OR IF
THEY REALLY BELIEVE THEM.
>> REMEMBER THESE TWO BROTHERS
WERE BORN IN NORTH KOREA.
IT'S THE ONLY WORLD THEY KNOW.
WHATEVER THEY WERE TOLD ABOUT
THE OUTSIDE WORLD I AM CERTAIN
WAS VERY LIMITED AND PURPOSELY
CHOSEN AND SELECTED.
>> Reporter: HUMAN RIGHTS
ADVOCATE SAYS HE DOESN'T THINK
JAMES AND TED WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO LEAVE NORTH KOREA, EVEN IF
THEY WANTED TO.
WOULD THEIR FATHER BE PUNISHED
BY THE U.S. MILITARY IF HE LEFT?
NO COMMENT FROM THE PENTAGON ON
THAT.
ANOTHER AMERICAN DEFECTOR WAS
COURT MARCH SCHAAD WHEN HE LEFT
NORTH KOREA BUT WAS SENTENCED TO
ONLY 25 DAYS.
THE PENTAGON SAID THERE HAVE
BEEN